when our tensions in the Conservative
Party look like reaching boiling point
after in Duncan Smith's shock
resignation he's been accused this
morning of trying to cause maximum
damage to the conservative leadership
his former colleague the pensions
minister ROS Altmann says it was all
part of his campaign to get Britain out
of the EU well I'm joined now by one of
mr. Duncan Smith's allies in the party
burner Jenkin he's chair of the public
administration committee he's in
Chelmsford and a very good morning to
you mr. Jenkin I mean it looks like this
so mum penning salvo has been fired in a
conservative civil war here Emily in
Duncan Smith on this morning that
defending explaining his reasons amber
Rudd's just been on my program saying
she's a bit puzzled as to why he
resigned well anybody who watched in
being interviewed on Andrew Marr this
morning can't possibly doubt his
integrity his passion but what he is
stayed in politics for which is to help
the least able to help themselves back
into economic activity back into work
that's why he started the center for
social justice as soon as he stepped
down as leader of the Conservative Party
it was his experiences being leader that
completely changed his politics he once
told me that what he'd seen on the
streets of Glasgow in other inner cities
had completely changed his politics his
personal priorities the only reason he
came into the government to serve David
Cameron at all was in order to pursue
this agenda and here am I I'm a fellow
Euroskeptic and I got quite frustrated
with him because he would not resign
over the European question but no for
him the the whole issue of this welfare
reform and helping vulnerable people has
been to him much much more important
than anything else in his lobby well
that therefore mr. Jenkin by implication
and amber rudder addressed this she
feels there there been spirit smeared
those that still support that budget
you're saying mr. Duncan Smith said it
wasn't a one nation budget because of
those cuts for middle income earners
which is part of your manifesto because
that was then balanced on one side by
these further cuts to disability
benefits
so I am being filmed in the grounds of
my mother-in-law's house and she does
not need to receive a 200 pound per year
winter fuel allowance Iain Duncan Smith
has always been denied any suggestion
that he could start raining back on some
of these very generous benefits to
better off pensioners he's always been
told these cuts have got to bear on
working families people trying to get
back into work disabled people who want
to work now just ask yourself should we
be protecting rich pensioners in order
to be able to cut benefits for people
who are trying to do the right thing and
struggling with their lives and their
families this has got out of balance and
he's been struggling with this balance
for some time and frankly for the
government to keep saying oh were very
perplexed we don't understand why in
Duncan Smith has resigned I mean they
are deliberately trying to fog the
atmosphere it is deeply insincere for
them to pretend they don't know why in
Duncan Smith has resigned and it is just
don't want to hear they cannot hear and
I think the the highest level point on
this is about how Downing Street
operates it is they've just taken the
same playbook as brown and Blair
everything is dictated from the top for
short-term political Vantage everything
is tactical this cannot go on and the
point in Duncan Smith made today about
cabinet government and Jacob rees-mogg
has made the same point I've written
about it in the observer today we need
to reset how Whitehall operates you have
government departments with secretaries
of state running them because they
should have responsibility and the
Chancellor and the Prime Minister are
just part of a team the Prime Minister
is meant to be primos into Paris he's
not meant to be a dictator that the
Treasury is not meant to control
everything that goes on in government
departments and ian is not the only
minister who has got deeply frustrated
with short-term decisions which have
huge impact on government policies in
departments
which haven't been properly thought
through I mean amber Rudd should look at
her energy policy our energy policy is a
disaster we are talking about running
out of electricity over the next few
years because there has been so much
short-termism in energy policy we've had
six years in government to grip this and
we haven't and we've now got the most
expensive electricity in Europe just
about and the least secure energy
supplies and we can we can't even build
our first nuclear power station it's
still in chaos this is that is an
example of where the Treasury has ridden
roughshod over the department for energy
and we've still got chaos in policy and
I appreciate ministers in government
have to put your brave face on things
because they have to show unity but I've
Radian Duncan Smith on this question
just snapped all right well given the
the callousness I suppose you describe
bird George Osborne as presiding over
how fit is he in your estimation to
become leader of your party and Prime
Minister well we are not looking at a
leadership election in the short term
George Osborne has had an extremely
difficult job to do his Chancellor he is
in many ways it's done a good job we're
now borrowing only one pound in every 14
just remember what he inherited we were
borrowing one pound in every four pounds
that was being spent on police on
hospitals on the council is the
leadership we've made huge progress I'm
not going to discuss the leadership
today at the point is this is a wake-up
call for the Conservative Party to look
at how we run Whitehall how we can
change into a more collegiate more
collective style of government set aside
this European argument which has long
divided the Conservative Party how we go
forward after this referendum to have a
more collective more collegiate more
understanding more trusting leadership
of Whitehall than we've had this
constant briefing that comes out of
number 10 about ministers against
ministers who are saying inconvenient
truths what we want is people to be able
to talk about the truth I think
the British public are desperate for
ministers to share truth with each other
and then do the best thing in the
national interest okay chairman thank
you very much in the burner genk in
there the chair of the public
administration committee